least five people have been reported
dead in a shooting at a gay nightclub in
Colorado let's go straight to our
Newsroom and speak to Skies Emma
Berkeley who has the latest for us Emma
what's happened yeah so it was just a
few minutes before midnight local times
that's four hours ago now that the call
came in to police about a shooting at
Club Q in Colorado Springs this is a
nightclub described as adult orientated
gay and lesbian nightclub there was an
immediate response as you'd expect by
the Emergency Services officers entered
the nightclub and very quickly a suspect
was taken into custody a suspect who
themselves was injured and is actually
being treated in hospital this has been
described by the police as a mass
casualty event as well as the police
that attended also 11 ambulances that
lined the roads and 34 firefighters now
there has been seen a statement from
Club Q on their Facebook page which has
said Club queue is devastated by the
senseless attack on our community our
prayers and thoughts are with all the
victims and their families and friends
we thank the quick reactions of heroic
customers that subdued the government
and ended this hate attack so quite
clearly what we read There is that this
was something that was helped to bring
to a close by those other people inside
the nightclub who just witnessed this
horrific attack on fellow customers
that person
detained by fellow nightclub goers
before the Emergency Services arrived
this very much an ongoing case and the
police have made it clear that the
figures of five people dead and 18
injured could well change
hey Emma thank you very much